this is just I don't even know anymore
[Music]
so I wanted to get through most my San
Diego comic-con ketchup stuff before I
started talking about this but yeah this
was on my docket to talk about James
Gunn was very suddenly and
unceremoniously fired in he was in the
middle of I believe he's still in the
writing stage
I'm guardians the galaxy vol 2 that he
might have finalized the script
they might even might have been working
towards pre-production but our garden is
a galaxy vol 3 but he yeah he's gone and
I mean this was his franchise
effectively he built this into what it
was it's an entire very popular corner
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and of
course the question now becomes why and
that was my immediate question because
it was so sudden and so Swift my gut
sinking instinct was oh crap there's a
there's a physical assault story there's
a sexual harassment or something like
that came out and I wasn't completely
far off in that instinct but that's not
what happened so basically what happened
was a number of bloggers combed through
his Twitter feed and you need to realize
this would this was something they would
have had to go really go out of their
way to do because he's a prolific
tweeter he tweets a lot so they would
have had to gone through thousands if
not tens of thousands of tweets to dig
up basically a whole bunch of
inappropriate jokes and I am actually
going to say jokes because I'm someone
who very had a gut level
I don't excuse inexcusable things being
brushed off as jokes oh just take a joke
dude because jokes are like any anguish
than any language they can be used to
hurt
I am gonna be very clear that even with
me coming from that position
I do feel these were very clearly jokes
but they were absolutely in poor taste
there were a lot of people eeeh jokes
and joke remarks that he himself liked
young boys now there's no evidence that
he does there's no there's you know this
isn't a Jared from from Subway kind of
situation but this was something that he
very casually joked about on multiple
occasions there were I don't know how
many tweets there were I read about a
dozen of them now the thing is is as I
said they had to comb through his
Twitter feed to find these because the
ones that I saw ranged in dates from
2009 through 2012 now interestingly the
most recent one again of the ones that I
could find that had been dug up was July
of 2012 he was hired to start working on
Gardens the guys of all you won in
September of 2012 so all of this
predates his employment by Marvel and
Disney so but sort of here's the thing
I've been really kind of torn on this in
a lot of ways because first of all let
me be very clear about one thing this is
not a free speech issue he he made his
speech he was free to make his speech
freedom of speech does not mean freedom
of the consequences of what happens when
you say these things he had the freedom
to say them he said them they were on
Twitter and now there were consequences
from that so this is not a freedom of
speech issue so anyone who's gonna be
flooding my comment feed with that it's
not it's just not you are free to say
whatever you want and people are also
free to respond to the things you say
including firing you if they are your
employer so that's the first thing
that's what this absolutely is not but
the reason I find myself torn is that I
do honestly I am NOT gonna defend any of
these tweets not even on the basis of it
was a joke while I will ignore
that these were clearly jokes they're an
incredibly poor taste I don't think
they're funny they're offensive I'm not
going to defend any of these things the
other thing I'm going to set aside
although I'll acknowledge here is that
from what I could find the people who
dug this up were a number of
conservative pundits now I don't want to
drag politics into this overtly but I
have to I feel the need to acknowledge
the fact that James Gunn is a very
outspoken critic of Trump and of the GOP
in general and the people who dug
through his feed to find this stuff are
very decidedly on the opposite end of
that so it's hard to argue that this
wasn't a hit job like I said they would
have they would have had to comb through
thousands upon thousands of tweets from
six years ago plus to find what they
found like I said I'm acknowledging that
here but I'm also setting it aside
because regardless of who found it and
what their motivation was for finding it
it's still real it's not doctored it's
not fate this isn't Project Veritas
situation where it's a heavily edited
video to make it seem like he said
something he didn't say these were his
exact words that they found and
presented so regardless of the
motivation what they found was real so I
have to set that aside as well so that
leaves me with what he said but also
when he said it so the reason I found
myself torn on this is I find it
difficult to defend his confused
employment in the light of these kinds
of comments if they were being made
while he was being employed by somebody
in there and I'm not saying this in the
terms of anything you did before you
were employed by someone who's offended
by something you did prior to that is
somehow off the table I mean new
information can come to light and they
can you know find out something that you
used to do prior to you being employed
by them and they're within their rights
to your interview if that makes them
uncomfortable or in the case of a large
global company like Marvel and Disney if
it is bad for their image they're within
their rights to do that but the thing is
is that in this case what was dug up was
just words like I said I
happen so quickly I was expecting this
to have been charges of physical assault
and it wasn't and for something that was
ultimately just words and again very bad
jokes very poorly deal I I didn't find
any of these funny and there wasn't even
if you found them funny they're
unquestionably offensive and in poor
taste but still very clearly jokes and
so just words and not even words were
it's like him you know saying racist
things of him you know saying homophobic
now there was one transphobic one and
need to acknowledge that most of them
were had paedophile natures there was a
transphobic one which I didn't like
seeing but again clearly intended as a
joke a bad joke that didn't lamb but a
joke and the other thing is James got
himself and the thing is you look at his
public profile and I actually do believe
him it I'm very measured I'm very
selective on when I believe in trouble
celebrities with what they offer as an
explanation I always look at the context
because I'm never gonna take these
people at their word flat-out even the
ones I like because look you're in a
situation where you're in trouble you're
trying to get out of it I need to
scrutinize whatever it is you say that
you're trying to get out of trouble so
what he said and again my knowledge of
him and having I knew about James Gunn
as a as a director as a creator before
he was doing gardens of the galaxy I saw
super not long after it first came out
on DVD and so and I knew about his work
on trauma but I'm kind of I'm gonna kind
of come back to that so this whole thing
what's weird about it to me is that
while it is not consistent with the man
he is now because he did say that he's
his attitude and what he feels is
appropriate has changed I do think the
fact that they had to go minimum six
years back to find this stuff is
reflective of that or at the very least
roughly
shifting a public persona if not a
private one who knows but who he is now
does not appear to be who he was then
which is what he said and I do believe
him for that so ultimately I have come
to the conclusion that I'm not okay with
this because if not only does it feel
excessively reactionary did Marvel not
know who it was that they had fired
because these tweets these kinds of
jokes this kind of humor
that's who James Gunn was in 2012 2011
2010 12 2009 that's who he was
did they not look into the man did they
did none of them see super did none of
them see his work on trauma did they
just look at his resume and go oh he
wrote the scooby-doo movies he'll be
fine and then not investigate who he was
not that I'm saying they needed to
heavily vet him but it was not very far
into his past as a creative film person
that those sorts of comments and jokes
and tweets were incredibly consistent
with his output at the time that they
hired him so the reason I'm not okay
with this ultimately after having kind
of being torn about it and sleeping on
it the reason I'm ultimately not okay
with this is it is completely
reactionary to the response to old stuff
that a I would argue Disney possibly
Channel about maybe not me okay Disney
it would have been net too much to ask
them to comb through his Twitter but
knowing the kind of things that he made
I would have thought upon hiring him
especially at this point now these
completely two films and was working on
a third that they would have been
prepared to stand by him and go yes we
know what he was like then we stand by
him now and I I do understand the
hesitation to do that because that kind
of argument when applied to a lot of
stuff that
has gone on particularly when we're
talking about things like the me2
movement like people who have actually
been accused of full-on sexual assault
or rape or you know anything of that
nature
I do understand the hesitation because
the defense that you would give to
continuing to employ someone like James
Gunn in the wake of these tweets being
dug up does parallel the kinds of
excuses that had historically been given
to justify why people with these long
lists of accusations or paid off you
know people or whatever would continue
to be employed like well that was them
we're not holding it against him but you
know we're reaching an age where a
significant portion of society is going
what they did was inexcusable you should
not be defending them it doesn't matter
how long ago was I mean that's I mean
we've got conviction on Bill Cosby for
that so there's been a societal shift
and I do understand Disney's desire to
not be on the wrong side of history and
regards like that but this feels like an
overcorrection this was then over
defending themselves at the cost of I
would say one of their best creative
assets especially because not only was
he working on guarding the galaxy 3 well
that was gonna be his last one and he
wasn't going to he wasn't planning to
make more movies for Disney he had been
given carte blanche and encouraged by
Marvel by Kevin Feige and the others to
set up what would be the future of the
Marvel cosmic stuff which presumably
would include the Eternals movie which
got announced a little bit ago so they
asked a lot of him and dismissed him
very very quickly and that is really
disappointing and again I'm not
necessarily going to make the argument
that it was 100% the wrong thing to do
in terms of letting
go I do feel that doing it as swiftly as
they did really tips their hand as to
why they did it though because the fact
that when I saw that firing I had to
look up what had happened to me
indicates that Disney and Marvel fired
him basically as soon as they found out
they didn't find out look into it figure
out what this meant what it would mean
for them to defend it this was not this
this does not come across in any way
like a measured decision this comes
across 100% like a knee-jerk reaction
and again it's not like he was he was
accused of physically assaulting because
that is a situation where let's go
hypothetical for a second if he had been
accused of rape of physical assault of
you know sexual intimidation anything of
that nature they would they the right
thing would have been to remove him
immediately so you get him out of the
work environment so he's not a hazard
and you know and then make the decision
you know while he's off do we figure
this out which honestly that's basically
what Disney did with John Lasseter
because John Lasseter got accused by you
know a number of I don't want to say Q's
a number of stories came out about John
Lasseter and John Lasseter's behavior
that they removed him from his position
heading Pixar but then in I think it was
six months something like that when no
one came forward to actually register a
formal complaint and let's be clear that
does not mean he didn't do anything it
just mean nobody wanted to put their
name on the on the record of a formal
complaint about it but because no one
did make a formal complaint they brought
him back in a different position and
he's being monitored he went through
training did all these things they but
they removed him quickly which was the
right thing to do here
they not only removed him quickly when
so far as I can tell nothing about these
tweets indicates that he was a threat or
hazard to anybody other than Disney's
image and fired him not we're taking him
off this give us a give us a little time
we're gonna figure this out like gone
it's that fickleness
that I find kind of professionally
offensive there was no professional
courtesy granted and that's not
professional courtesies not automatic
professional courtesy a should be earned
and be if what you do is atrocious
enough professional courtesy can be
disregarded and should be but he did
more than enough to earn some
professional courtesy and as far as what
has come out at the time that I'm
recording this
I don't feel justifies an immediate
firing and I probably wouldn't be so
annoyed if there had been more time if I
knew this was a choice that Disney came
to as something other than just oh
trouble dumped him I think that this is
a decision that they're going to regret
greatly down the line I for a multitude
of reasons I think they're gonna regret
his loss on the film even if they keep
his script and have somebody else direct
it I think we're gonna feel the
difference I think they're going to deal
with probably a hefty amount of backlash
for the swiftness with which they did
this and yeah I think that's just where
I'll and so until and unless something
else comes out the law of the short
version is James Gunn said some very
stupid and some very offensive things
between nine and six years ago which
were consistent with his public persona
at the time a public persona that I feel
Disney was or they should have been
aware of at the time they hired him and
he has not behaved made those kind of
statements or made those kind of jokes
since have you been employed by Disney
and Marvel so I feel that the swiftness
with which he was dismissed is
inappropriate so there we go
and I feel like I just summed up in
maybe 30 seconds what I've spent I don't
know maybe 20 minutes rambling about god
I dragged on I mean part of it is that
often times I don't I don't know 100%
what I'm going to say I sit down to do
these I'm actually working it out as I'm
talking sometimes because sometimes
talking about it out loud to you folks
is how I get a firmer sense of what my
feelings actually are because sometimes
I have to hear myself and where I put my
emphasis and what's actually getting me
upset get it out of my head and get it
out and then it firms up a bit better
anyways the whole James gun being fired
thing what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do I won't list it I do
have a patreon that's the big one but
links to that and a bunch of other stuff
it's all down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]